that is a horrible and immoral system to
have in my opinion the Federal Reserve
makes all that possible and that's why I
think it's got to go hi i'm tim
cavanaugh for Reason TV
we're here with tad Lumpkin writer
producer and director of American dream
an animated short film looking at the
Federal Reserve American dream is out
you can find it on YouTube it's kind of
spread virally and it's probably posted
on 50 different YouTube channels now but
if you add them up we've had about six
six or seven hundred thousand views
probably the the main determining factor
in governmental economics in America
right now is about public sector workers
and their compensation specifically
their pension post retirement yep
compensation you also have you know
these massive wars that have been going
on forever and will go on forever
what is the feds role in all of this
when you look at any war they fought you
know the Civil War and you deplete the
Treasury of the gold I mean you were
limited by what you had as to what you
could do there hasn't been that limit
it's been a progressive change
there's the Federal Reserve Act in 1913
as you move through time there's further
and further disassociation with gold
there's looser banking standards there's
preferential treatment for merging into
larger and larger financial institutions
who are some of the biggest players in
the financial markets or pension
associations they want more and more of
the capital to be committed to more and
more finance which is the reason why
banks and financial institutions roles
have become over emphasized in their and
their true importance in the world
they've hijacked the system to say we
get unlimited streams of money from the
Federal Reserve
we've geared all the laws so that
everything is in large pools of
investment capital where you've got
people forced to invest just to keep up
with the rate of inflation and they're
not doing it because it's like well
here's a really good business
opportunity where I think I can take my
hard-earned money put it at risk and
make more hard-earned money it's like
well if I use it or lose it I mean
either deploy it put it in the system or
it evaporates to nothing that is a
horrible and immoral
system to have in my opinion the Federal
Reserve makes all that possible and
that's why I think it's got to go you
take on the Federal Reserve in this
movie and it contains a lot of parodies
of popular movies 300 Back to the Future
and so forth what are you aiming to do
we felt like there's a lot of excellent
material out there organizations like
reason there's been books written like
an the Fed Ron Paul how do you bridge
the gap with your friends or your family
members that may know nothing may not
really see why they need to know
something aren't going to commit to
reading a book don't want to watch a
documentary we need to market Austrian
economics we can't just lay it out and
say oh it's the best everyone should
follow it because we think so
I think you need to tell people why you
got to come up you got to brand it hey
buddy need some money free money guy
told me free money give us it and an
idea of what's in the movie we tried to
take a very you know a prototypical guy
who was in a prototypical situation lost
his house lost his job was struggling
and was falling behind and losing his
American Dream and we felt like by
having a ghost of Christmas past sort of
methodology that we could walk our
citizen through and show him this is why
you're losing your American dream
this is why this is going to matter to
you your kids and frankly the future of
America and why this is important denne
equals money title remember that debt
equals money the more loans they make
the more money they make there are some
liberties with history that you take
there's a bit about the Rothschild
Battle of Waterloo career story which
has been fairly well debunked he's
everyone back
the news of the world I told England
that Napoleon won the red shield bankers
of London pretended that England was
doomed and started selling their English
stocks the IRS is depicted as a big
monster with a Rothschild logo for ahead
why do that why not tell the story more
straightforward
well because with the Rothschilds for
example we use a lot of conceptual ideas
to make a point we kind of pin them as
the first sort of mega global
organization global sort of banking
financial organization the use of their
shield isn't to say they run it all now
it's more to represent the idea of kind
of high finance and the fact that they
sort of took it to the next level with
the Waterloo and the front-running
they did have the information first now
the question is did they ever trade on
it or not I don't know goldman sachs
gets accused of front-running
people black box trade again it's the
idea of who's got the power or maybe
they didn't use it for bad maybe they
did I don't really know but it's the
idea of why are we putting so much of
our trust into people whose primary
motivation is expansion of influence and
and their own personal gain in some of
the iconography there's like a lot of
octopus imagery and so forth much of
which is you know an octopus is a good
metaphor for something that has its
tentacles all over the place
however that also has a history and
anti-semitic imagery and we're also
talking about the Rothschilds any
concerns there or have you heard
anything about that I haven't heard
anything about the octopus per se being
an anti-semitic image people it's not
kosher to eat anyway yeah that's not I'm
not anything specifically on that
there's been a couple people who've
brought up we're using the Rothschild
doesn't that mean does that mean you're
proliferating some sort of anti-semitism
the fact that these guys came from a
Jewish heritage doesn't does that then
mean they're off-limits to use as a bad
guy so then if they weren't from Jewish
heritage then that would mean you know
they were they were Polish heritage so
they were anti polish we're
anti-semites we're not promoting
anything to do with that the point
wasn't anti-semitism to the point is to
stir the pot speaking of stirring the
pot there's a lot of sort of cartoon
violence through the whole thing we're
in an era of a special sensitivity about
all that kinds of stuff since gabriel
giffords everybody's blaming everybody
except the shooter for the shooting any
concerns there I don't think anybody or
I hope not
thinks we're saying go kick Hank Paulson
in a pit but again its idea it's like
stand up and do something and like let's
go get motive what is the movies call to
action what are you supposed to do after
you've seen this movie there's not a
reason for violence but there is a
reason for civil disobedience there's a
reason to put marches together to vote
for people you know who want to shake
the system up like the Ron Paul's of the
world they want to shake the system up
that is how we change things and that's
what we're advocating how does
eliminating the Fed or in some way
pinioning the Fed get us toward actual
management of the size and nature of
government by the people rather than by
the Harvard Business School so many
people put their faith in these elites
because they have these degrees it's the
same guys from the same school and it's
like well let's hand over the entire
economy and the monetary system too you
know nine guys who think they're smarter
than everybody else as opposed to the
free market that whole idea of other
people being responsible for our lives
is is completely broken and why we're
why we're in this scenario the Federal
Reserve itself
anytime you give unlimited capacity to
print money then you're then the
government's going to grow and the think
the reason they laugh at gold and they
hate silver and this and that they make
fun of all these hard currencies as
being old-fashioned is because that's
the anchor that prevented them from
growing they have to live like every
other person does shrink when times are
lean and they can do more when you know
times are good we're still up against a
world where most people believe the
government shouldn't be shrinking when
it when times are lean that's when they
should be taking an active role in
taking up the surplus supply and all of
the
other Keynesian notions but I would
argue that's the reason why these things
continue to go on I mean what happens is
is if you don't let the system reset and
resources in capital liquidate and
reallocate then you don't ever fix the
problem you just medicate the symptom
you cannot spend more than you make and
just inflate the dollar into infinity at
some point there will be a mathematical
stopping point to that it's just really
irresponsible I think the reason that
we're losing our middle class has
nothing to do with regulation and big
business out of control it's got to do
with the fact that we don't have free
markets we don't have real money the
things that we're telling that our
politicians sell is helping the common
man are really the cause of the common
man's demise that's why we're trying to
make mass consumable entertainment that
gets those people awakened and fired up
we need voters we need people to hit the
street and and protest and vote and
spread the word and be part of the
solution